people wanting to go away for holidays
may be in for a turbulent summer
airlines around the world are struggling
with strikes staff shortages and the
lingering fallout of pandemic
lockdowns scandinavian airline sas has
filed for bankruptcy protection in the
u.s
it's blamed a pilot walkout over wages
on monday although its financial woes
have been long running success needs to
address its challenging financial
position
and make significant cost reductions in
order to become
competitive
the ongoing strike
makes this challenging situation even
tougher
in the uk low cost airline easyjet has
been forced to cut 10 000 of its
scheduled 160 000 flights the carrier
blames worker shortages saying the
problem is a lack of ground staff
on monday easyjet announced that chief
operating officer peter bellow had
stepped down to pursue other
opportunities
british airways passengers are also
affected
the carrier is cancelling about 1 500
flights in the coming weeks saying the
aviation sector is facing the most
challenging period in its history
we've got a pilot shortage we've got a
fuel crisis with prices just going out
of sight we've got inflation we need to
fill those seats to get what we call the
load factor up it's a series of problems
involving labor issues
involving
shortages of personnel the air traffic
controllers are very affected by this
on friday airport workers went on strike
in paris demanding higher wages
food and fuel prices are rising but
employees complain their salaries aren't
keeping pace
with companies unwilling or unable to
meet workers demands coupled with a
staff shortage it's shaping up to be a
difficult summer for both airlines and
passengers
laura about a manly al jazeera